[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow um GG's a basketball player she is
that she's in it does she have that in
her focus like her daddy yeah she's uh
she just don't go killer out there yeah
yeah at both ends of the floor I mean
she plays defense as well as offense man
she competes
how was she handling because now there's
a lot of YouTube videos out there like
Kobe's daughter destroys other girls
how's that going oh she's not tripping
about it I mean you know it's the you
know what I try to teach the girls and I
just heard about all the girls on the
team is it's a process you just work
every day and we only started playing
about a year ago right so he's just
chipping away I just get better and
better
she told me she says see that hard work
makes the dream work
that's the best
[Music]
we're just really blessed very fortunate
you have three beautiful healthy you
know young ladies and there's another
one on the way so which is just very
very fortunate
[Music]
you